it's just a pre-season but the browns
radio network in post-season four my god
hey i like the excitement and they're
clearly excited in cleveland chris the
first team offense looked great baker
mayfield looked great rashard higgins a
guy who has quietly leapfrogged antonio
callaway and is in position to be the
number three receiver behind jarvis
landry and odell beckham jr getting it
done brown's getting it done a lot of
excitement you were in cleveland this
week great to see mayfield back on the
field and i think the sky's the limit
for that offense especially with obj in
the fold yeah i mean jarvis landry obj
they're not even on the field but i mean
wow i mean that was let's
just a little eye opening again i'll say
mike you talked about i was in cleveland
baker mayfield the tv doesn't do justice
to him the ball pops out of his hands at
a faster velocity uh in person than i
even thought and i i was impressed with
him before i saw him in person but man
some of those throws coming out the way
they just came out to start the
preseason i know it's the preseason and
everything like that but to just be able
to march down the field with precision
lasers all over the place and then make
a throw like that to score on your first
drive of the nfl preseason i mean just
impressive and you know hopefully a
thing uh a sign of the future for for
the browns coming this year
five for six 77 yards and a touchdown
for baker mayfield the first overall
pick in 2018 became the starter in week
three and will never look back i think
as long as he's healthy enough to play
he's the guy in cleveland indefinitely
and the browns the high expectations
it's it's gonna it's gonna be critical
that weak one can they hold serve at
home against the tennessee titans if
they if they can often run and go the
browns in 2019. all right the jets with
a guy who was taken third overall back
in 2018 sam darnold four for five for 68
yards and a touchdown he looked good
last night right new offense still a
work in progress with that jets offense
but with adam gase there drawing things
up he hasn't had a quarterback like sam
darnold in a long time if ever i mean he
got peyton manning on the downside of
his career darnold arguably could be the
best quarterback overall that gase has
had and he's got a lot of different
things he can do with that offense and
we saw a little bit of it last night yes
we did very true statement and what
you're saying too might be the most
talented guy that adam gase ever had
because yeah it was peyton manning
towards the end of his career and he
wasn't necessarily throwing lasers
around the field anymore but uh man
i just think it's going to be a great
relationship because adam gates is going
to have so many plays every game or he's
going to make it easy for sam darnold
and then when things aren't easy we saw
last night like that first third down
you know his movement and feel in the
pocket he's got that great sense like
baker mayfield just moving around
keeping his eyes downfield oh it's
backyard football again no problem i'm
comfortable in this bam hit somebody
down the field as he's kind of attacking
the line of scrimmage i think it's uh
got a chance to be a very successful
marriage there and sam darnold and adam
gase and i'm expecting that offense and
sam donna donald look really good this
year
and you've got 42 year old tom brady and
three second year quarterbacks in that
afc east division and the the bills jets
dolphins all jostling to try to fill the
void that they assume will emerge when
tom brady retires i have a feeling that
that may not be a valid assumption
because bill belichick may have a thing
or two up his sleeve lamar jackson
extended playing time last night but no
rushing attempts chris four for six
throwing the ball 59 yards and a
touchdown and i think what the ravens
are going to do in the preseason they're
going to continue to keep everyone
guessing about what their offense is
going to be and i think that offense is
going to change week by week opponent by
opponent but they are going to try to
keep people on their heels every snap
every drive every game isn't gonna be a
run is it gonna be a pass we don't know
and we'll find out once lamar jackson
does whatever he does with the football
it was a good start uh i wasn't blown
away like lamar jackson again i'm
excited to see this offense and i know
it's going to be different and what's
going to be asked of lamar jackson is
going to be different uh as far as him
compared to the rest of the nfl but hey
the real the big thing is i know the
bootlegs and the scrambling and all
that's going to be good that's right up
his alley what i want to continue to see
is what we shoot
showed at the end of that clip in the
pocket little slot out route in the
pocket back shoulder foot back shoulder
throw to the guy down the sideline not
totally positive he was throwing to that
guy yet but either way he got it
complete i'm not going to judge it too
harshly good start for him but that's
what i want to continue to see with
lamar jackson just make me feel
comfortable with that baltimore ravens
team because i just don't feel like
you're going to out gimmick every team
in the nfl week after week after week
with just run game and overpowering
people so
encouraging nonetheless for lamar
and maybe that's the lesson they learned
last year in that home playoff loss to
the la chargers after they had played
the chargers and beat them in their own
building a couple of weeks earlier we
can't be one-dimensional we can't come
out and
and allow the defense to presume what
we're going to do we have to keep
everyone guessing look that is such a
key component and it's so simple in
football if the defense doesn't know
whether or not it's a run or a pass
they're on their heels at the snap right
chris yes that you get it you get an
extra advantage you know when the snap
is coming you know what the play is
going to be and they don't until it
begins to materialize and if you can
disguise it as long as you possibly can
you have a better chance of being
successful yes you do and and all that
stuff we're talking about right all
those things the run game all everything
don't show any of it in the preseason
baltimore make lamar jackson just keep
throwing the ball and being a pocket
passer
hey get them reps doing that because we
know we can do the other stuff like we
said and we know that offense is going
to be different too to where don't show
anybody what you're going to do let
everybody try to figure it out on the
fly once the regular season starts so i
hope they kind of continue to that trend
and really force the issue of maybe him
making decisions within the pocket you
know not going crazy with it but we all
know he needs reps in that department
and that that offense like you're saying
it can't be as one-dimensional as it was
last year
josh rosen who was drafted 10th overall
by the cardinals in 2018 traded to the
dolphins for a second round pick
competing with ryan fitzpatrick he was
13 for 20 191 yards and an interception
last night extended duty for him a mixed
bag i think he's got a long way to go
but again it's relative he's competing
with ryan fitzpatrick and every time you
think fitzpatrick is bad he plays well
you think he's going to play well he
plays poorly the door is going to be
open for rosen at some point to take
that job i would think so you know i of
course was watching this game very
closely because my brother was was also
playing for the atlanta falcons
rosen he's such a pure beautiful thrower
of the football uh i just think it's
only a matter of time before he
overtakes a guy like ryan fitzpatrick
the interception hey that was dumb he
was a bad mistake he kind of stared down
the guy didn't have a feel for where the
linebacker was but okay it's preseason
game number one and a whole new system
and surroundings all that but he bounced
back from that and uh really i thought
striped uh some really nice passes in
there so pure throw such a pretty ball
josh rosen it's effortless
matt sims by the way who just joined the
falcons over the weekend eight for 17 86
yards three sacks though for matt sims
tell your brother get rid of the ball
yeah seriously matt get rid of the ball
and find it out it was a good start for
him too uh wasn't perfect he did some
good things he'll learn from it but yeah
the big thing is like you said he's only
been there for about six or seven days
and he's kind of getting his feet wet uh
next week we gotta see a big jump from
my bro and uh hopefully he can make that
football team
and there's an opportunity the the
youngster uh that they have on the
roster benker on ir now match yeah and
matt shaw
still matt schaab all due respect so
there's an opportunity there
for matt sims all right last one before
we take a break josh allen your guys six
for 11 66 yards nothing outstanding
right they're not they're not going to
be firing 80 yard missiles down the
field but but it's this work in progress
in buffalo that's kind of quietly
grinding and building towards something
that can be competitive in the afc east
or for a wild card spot in the afc and
you like what sean mcdermott is doing i
like what sean mcgregor's doing and we
both think josh allen has great
potential it's all just a matter of
harnessing it yeah and reaching his
maximum limit that's right it's a little
bit like lamar jackson and the fact
where we know he's got all these
physical tools a big arm he can run he
can do all that let's just continue to
get him reps in the pocket making
decisions having to throw some of those
short passes and being accurate with
that not being overly aggressive at
times and going hey you don't have to
force the 40-yard missile down the field
there's a guy five yards over the middle
let's hit him it's those type of things
that josh allen just got to continue to
grow in and i i fully expect them to one
because of the coaching mcdermott brian
dayball and i've been around josh allen
kid's no idiot he's aware of what's
going on he's aware of what he needs to
improve and he's got great talent and i
think
i think he will get a get a get a hold
of how to play quarterback in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports